aquí vemos que tenemos varias líneas que
se intersectan de diferentes maneras
formando triángulos y ya que tenemos
algunos valores de estos ángulos como
estos señalados aquí lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es encontrar el valor de
este ángulo x les pido en este momento
que ustedes detengan el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo por su propia cuenta si lo
han intentado entonces pueden volver a
poner continuar a este vídeo para que
vean cómo les muestro yo la solución de
esto y lo interesante es que tenemos
diferentes maneras de resolver esto así
que ustedes pueden hacer diferentes
intentos aquí vamos a comenzar con el
ángulo que se encuentra más a la
izquierda tenemos que es un ángulo de
121 grados y este ángulo es
suplementario al ángulo que se encuentra
por acá así que este ángulo de 121
grados más este ángulo que dibuje en
verde tienen que ser igual a 180 grados
así que este ángulo será 180 grados
menos 121 grados esto es lo mismo que
restar 80 menos 21 y 80 menos 21 es 5
y 9 grados así que quito esto de acá y
escribo 59 grados y ahora vemos que
tenemos dos ángulos de un niño triángulo
cuando tenemos esto podemos encontrar el
tercer ángulo ya que la suma de todos
los ángulos internos de este triángulo
tiene que ser igual a 180 grados así que
59 más 29 más me interrogante debe ser
igual a 180 si restamos 59 y el 29 al
180 nos queda no esta interrogación es
igual a 180 menos 59 menos 29 y ahora
vamos a hacer 180 menos 59 pues ya
sabemos que es 121 ahora 121 menos 29
nos va a quedar bueno si restamos nada
más los 20 nos va a quedar 101 y a ese
101 le quitamos el 9 y nos va a quedar
entonces 192 así que aquí escribo 92
grados así que tenemos este ángulo de 92
grados y este ángulo de aquí es vertical
con respecto a éste
así que también tendrá 92 grados y ahora
sí ya nos estamos acercando si vemos más
de cerca este triángulo permíteme hacer
un poco de espacio aquí aquí pongo que
este ángulo es de 92 grados y en este
triángulo de aquí abajo ya conocemos dos
de sus ángulos internos y si conocemos
dos ángulos de un triángulo podemos
calcular el tercer ángulo así que si ya
tenemos estos dos no necesitamos saber
mucha matemática para encontrar el valor
de este tercer ángulo tenemos un ángulo
que es 29 otro ángulo que es 92 180
menos 29 menos 92 va a ser 59 y no
tenemos que hacer el cálculo porque en
este otro triángulo tenemos exactamente
los mismos ángulos así que en este caso
este tercer ángulo va a ser de 59 grados
pues y aquí la suma fue de 180 grados
aquí también la suma va a dar 180 grados
por lo que este ángulo va a ser de 59
grados este es el resultado de restar
180 grados menos 29 menos 92
y si este es 59 grados este otro ángulo
nuestro ángulo incógnita también va a
ser 59 grados como les comenté al
principio hay muchas maneras de resolver
esto vamos a hacer otra forma para
resolverlo así que ahora permiten un
momento para volver a iniciar todo como
estaba en un principio ahora que ustedes
ya pueden hacer estos pasos básicos
pueden resolver esto diciendo mira aquí
tengo este ángulo externo de 121 grados
que debe ser igual a la suma de estos
dos ángulos internos que se encuentran
opuestos esto es igual a lo que hicimos
hace un momento paso a paso pero aquí
estamos usando algunas de las cosas que
ya sabemos sobre los triángulos y de
esta manera ahorrarnos algunos pasos
aunque yo quise comenzar haciéndolo de
la otra manera para asegurarnos que no
estemos haciendo ninguna cosa extraña
así que esto será 121 menos 29
igual a 92 92 y si este es 92 este va a
ser 92 si este es x éste va a ser x y
tenemos x más 92 más 20
igual a 180
x + 92 más 29 es igual a 121 que eso ya
lo sabíamos de acá y esto va a ser igual
a ciento ochenta 180 ahora x va a ser
igual a 59 59 grados así que como lo han
podido observar existen muchísimas pero
muchísimas formas de resolver este
problema